Hey, Sarah?
Huh? What the hell is this?
I remember...
I am... a researcher here.
They caught me when I was
exposing their experiments...
Experiments? About what?
XM. Exotic Matter.
It’s a quantum substance.
And they want to bend it to their will.
And that’s, uh... a bad thing?
XM. It has the capability to
directly affect the human mind.
In their hands,
it will be used to betray humanity.
We have to stop them!
Stop them? Sarah!
Do you hear yourself?
Oh... Sorry.
The thing is...
It’s so crazy,
even I wouldn’t believe it.
That’s what I felt in the vision...
She’s like me...
And she’s lost in all of this too.
But...
Makoto...
I need you to believe.
Because right now...
It’s us against the world.
I believe you.
Maybe we’re both crazy.